je vais vous dire un autre truc qui me
frappe c'est que voilà et quand les gens
me voient dans la rue une fois de plus
en plus de gens qui souffrent comme vous
voilà qu'il est de me voir qui me dit
série on n'arrive pas à boucler les fins
de mois on arrive chacun d'ailleurs non
mais je dis dans les séries et tous les
gens me disent notre seul loisir c'est
la télé c'est ce que me disait encore se
moque pas ses ratios de la diro là ils
nous regardent tous les soirs pour se
détendre voilà on fait en tout cas une
longueur pour se détendre le soir voilà
moi je vous dis j'ai peut-être qu'il ya
un truc à faire aussi comme comme
coluche avait créé je sais pas les
restos du coeur est ce qu a pas moyen
peut-être de créer avec le gouvernement
une banque du coeur peut-être pour
essayer de dd peut-être les plus
d'éléments non je pense que c'est
possible ça je pense qu'aujourd'hui une
pop tel qu'il est représenté
elle sépare et aussi peut-être créer un
truc comme ça je pense je pense qu'elles
peuvent pas être obligé de se
professionnaliser d'aller de se
structurer et d'insérer les institutions
françaises à un niveau à un niveau
beaucoup plus bas pour qu'un jour je
trouve pas ça normal qu'un président ils
puissent dépenser des millions et des
millions d'euros pour un déplacement je
trouve ça normal
je suis pas ça la vie à dépenser
j'aimerais vous parler aussi d'un petit
truc d'un symbole vous avez vu ce que
cette porsche qui a été retourné sa cage
et ça fait beaucoup parler sur les
réseaux sociaux
j'ai vu il ya des gens qui disent eh bah
c'est bien fait pour sa gueule parce que
il aurait pas dû acheter une porte et il
ya des non non il n'y a pas de là bas on
parle pas de la mamie qui s'est fait
bousculer bio la main s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît c'est de cette image n'a pas
trop content il ya eu un communiqué
est-ce que vous condamnez cette image
bien sûr au lounge à l'image d'ailleurs
la regarde et ben voilà on l'a des
réseaux est ce que ça vous le condamnez
ou pas j'espère qu'il est bien assurée
c'est quand même non mais ça vous le
condamnez a bien sûr un coût minime et
réussir dans ce sens donc forcément
quand le condamne d'accord pas résidé
historique falloir gérer le problème de
ce mouvement c'est qu'initialement le
président à maîtriser cet appel
ce mouvement citoyen quelles sont les
solutions parce qu'ils nous rappellent
attendait juste pour la solution moi
j'aimerais mais on a quand même des
personnes à la tête de l'état qui sont
payés entre cinq et quinze mille euros
c'est vrai les solutions oui mais non et
pour que non mais pour que tu as cannes
d'ici samedi
chauffer police afghane 10,6 avec sadie
est pas d'accord moi je demande qu'on
fait un break royal a fait un bref jaser
c'est pas nous c'est ne pas s'exprimer
de faire un break la sicile et gilet
jaune 10 sauf un break qui aura pas de
casseurs fait mais si les personnes ne
veut pas faire le break on va pas les
formes et moi je suis bien avec moi je
suis d'accord
jérémy je ne sais pas tous en même temps
marielle d'accord ce que vous dites je
suis d'accord avec ce que tu dis
pourquoi pas mais pour en faire quelque
chose pour faire la preuve une balle de
taxes matin monsieur macro mais des
plaintes et diviseur je sois là je
cherche je fait machine arrière
il a forcément nous sommes accrochés
vous donner ça ça ça le reste il ya
beaucoup de doléances et six structures
et voulait gilet jaune ce qui va être
fait dans les prochains jours ensuite je
vous recevrai avec votre cahier de
charges et là on va pouvoir avancer sans
mettre le paysage à 106,10 demain j'en
suis sûr s'il dit demain on bloque tout
ce qu'on a dit pour l'instant voilà
enfin en bloc comme vous je veux comme
vous avez dit vous vous voulez organiser
et je vais vous recevoir dès que vous
serez organisé et on va travailler sur
les choses ensemble est ce que ça peut
calmer les choses
est-ce que ça me dit vous pouvez ne pas
appeler chacun et de faire ce qu'il veut
sinon lanceur ça va ils sont passé si ya
pas de gilet jaune dollars us albi aura
pas de casseurs on comble octobre
mouvement monsieur mac web locaux en
échange les faciles pour les quatre
mouvements et monsieur macro et bloc
contre bloc pour l'instant tout ce qu'il
a annoncé ce que l'annoncé quoi et banon
mais voilà la hausse des taux ce qui
n'est pas mon cas je vous dirais oui
c'est suffisant parce que vaut mieux ça
que vaut mieux ça que le pire mais le
pire est devant mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous tous nous avons nous
sous sommes que des messages et des
gilet jaune
on nous a fait confiance pendant
quelques jours moi depuis samedi dernier
on me fais plus confiance pour une
transition pacifique elle que nos
gouvernements
à moins que deux mamans et sociaux de
bataille se passe quelque chose qui les
jaunes vous font plus confiance bas il
sait pas qui me font plus confiance
c'est qu'ils me font puis ils sont plus
assez patient pour croire en une
transition pacifique et il y en a
beaucoup plus haut plus les heures et
les jours passent plus il y en a parce
qu'il voit bien
c'est stérile convient sur les médias
qu'on recensait même chose qu on
reformule et ça bouge pas notre et ça
bouge pas ça bouge pas je rencontre des
gens on attend les chiffres ne vous est
pas représentatif à 100% de l'a86 bien
dit ces problèmes on souffle avec vous
mais avec cette violence là à fort se
finisse et parlée par les braquets il
suffit de voir sur notre page facebook
qui ouvert au public était d'ailleurs on
vous vous invite à venir débattre sans
aucun filtre ne doit pas de défaut car
oui exactement
nous ce que nous voulons c'est de
dialoguer ensemble nous on n'a
absolument rien mais alors dit casse toi
même ce qui nous dit on la prend pas ce
que j'ai j'ai freiné du réseau jartazi
les petits commerçants les tous les
indépendants et sur les tranquilles
dégageons les zones où on peut
travailler
sauf que vous avez l'air que j'étais
chez open en se calmant savez 80% des
gens qui soutiennent les gilet jaune
ils soutiennent 72 cents et gilet jaune
pacifié que c'est pas 80% s'est passé je
n'arriverais pas super fusion parce que
comme vous dites monsieur là ça peut
être dramatique 1 voilà c'est samedi ça
continue dramatique pour les commerçants
qui sont aussi des gilets jaunes dans la
population
parce qu'aujourd'hui les commerçants
sont remontés la population les
remontées aussi au pakistan faisant
break je pense qu on est sa négociation
va arriver on espère vraiment voilà que
ça va s'arranger mais a priori de ce que
vous me dites vous ni vraiment là il
faut qu'ils reviennent en arrière
surtout qu'ils annoncent des mesures
parce que ce moment par exemple
justement on veut pas on veut pas vite
une révolution pour en faire une autre
d'accord à un moment donné il ya des
réformes qui peuvent être très vives ou
six autres cas du tout vous allez très
vite on prenons l'argent même en faisant
l'autre circuler autrement pour vous
dire déjà c'est vrai monsieur